I think until your you yourself are
experiencing it's very difficult you
know it's very difficult mints one of
the reasons again why I made that film
but um we should all have that
connection to the soldiers who are
serving that every family member has and
if if we did maybe maybe certain things
would be very different but I think it's
very difficult to when I was in houma
it's a you know every time I would go to
home what was as if i was you know in a
country at war you know everyone was
speaking about the war everybody had a
family member or they knew someone who
was serving or had been killed and and
the impact was was was was significant
there when I come back home you know it
was it was completely different
environment so I think it's very
difficult to know what a family feels
until you're actually everyone people
can empathize and understand
conceptually but emotionally I think
it's very difficult to feel that that
that pain unless you're you actually
know someone mentally
you